un tout petit bureau avec un ordinateur
dans le coin d'une chambre à coucher
c'est ici que camil nasraoui rédige son
journal de mike green en arabe et en
anglais
une publication pour la communauté arabe
aux canadiennes et pour les réfugiés
syriens être annulées ne commencent les
nouveaux arrivants vivent avec cette
barrière de la langue dit-il
j'essaie de les aider c'est une barrière
que camil connaît lui et sa famille sont
arrivés au canada en février 2016 en
tant que réfugié il ne parlait pas
l'anglais et après deux mois de cours de
langues il a abandonné
il préférait apprendre en travaillant en
côtoyant des canadiennes youtube il a
aussi poursuivi son apprentissage de
l'anglais grâce à des vidéos sur youtube
camilla été journaliste au liban et à
damas en syrie d'où il est originaire en
arrivant au canada il a remarqué qu'il
n'y avait aucune publication pour les
réfugiés syriens
il a lancé deux migrants tome ouaddou
l'an passé à toronto
22000 des 52 mille réfugiés accueillis
entre 2015 et maintenant vivent dans la
région de la ville reine mais vers un
terrain j'avais les clés
si je peux aider leur intégration en
écrivant en arables sur les programmes
dette du gouvernement ou en leur offrant
des histoires inspirantes et un peu de
journalisme fouillé j'aurai réussi
affirme-t-il le journal de kamil
embaucher un autre journaliste et une
équipe de publicité pour générer des
revenus
le journal est disponible sur internet
ou de nouveaux articles sont
régulièrement mises en ligne outre
mesure car il nous montre avec fierté
les données sur le nombre de partages
des articles ainsi que sur le nombre de
visiteurs de son site web
plus de 580 mille visites depuis le
début de l'année
le journal mensuel en version papier lui
est maintenant distribuée dans quatre
villes où les réfugiés syriens sont
nombreux
montréal laval toronto mississauga hazel
expérience un article à la fois calme il
espère rapprocher les réfugiés syriens
des canadiens qui les ont accueillis ces
dernières années ici philippe leblanc
radio-canada torontois